hello reject nation it is Greg Alba here
and it is John Humphrey over here we're
gonna watch today from my brother's
channel with javi Kuwait channel that
Halloween thriller short film starring
him and a Chara Kirk
it's called stalker his videos
performing very well on his channel
actually not a reaction is performing
very well congrats to you Gaby I'm happy
for you Jon and I are putting together a
little Halloween on short on say it's
scary it's a Halloween short certainly
keep a lookout for it guys they'll be up
on Halloween my brother's not giving us
permission to use this footage so we
monetize we don't have express written
consent of Jabby KO a
[Music]
that's where he lives
have you see you guys all now Jabby
annoyed no I feel like [ __ ] eco a likes
that's a great image who shot this we'll
find out
hey it's me Lori yeah it's just loud
loud or even opposite of quiet yeah next
to the beach the waves just keep on
crashing by Mumbai
that's usually when I call it quits on
script
I've usually stopped before all this is
ours
cheat on her cheating on your girlfriend
mm-hmm in those goggles in her uncle's
place
[Music]
cool
[Music]
or was this yes
[Music]
it's really well done
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just wandering to someone else's home
this reminds me this thriller I saw
called swimming pool things was called
oh the Frenchman yeah
who's this a witness the woman knows in
the balcony what Willie stop okay I know
that I was a dick to you the other day
but this is too much why didn't you tell
me this before no that's silly you have
a bad feeling because you saw some
traumatic [ __ ] your brain is just trying
to work it out that's all
that's not because there's a ghost or
something I didn't say she looks exactly
like the woman I saw it's just a
coincidence she looks kind of similar no
it's the only logical explanation or
those ghosts really I'll be fine
please
now go that's I want this the end just
goes
the punchline
there's some really good sound design on
this thing yeah
as really creepy when she popped it yeah
might as well
Hey
[Music]
oh now she's not alone
[Music]
some might say
but just be free
[Music]
Sicard Oh Elliott the second sharukh
charge shot this pad at all it's amazing
looking this is a very visual story too
so like yeah that wow that's a nice
little quiet piece yeah material there
yeah it did remind me of that that movie
swimming pool were cuz she's an author
who goes to get away to write and then
the side ghost story but it's quiet it's
messed up stuff it's a quiet piece of
material and it's like this person's
getting sidetracked by other things and
can't write it's like what Stephen King
goes through once a month yeah it's like
it's like if you took that vibe and like
put a little J [ __ ] on top of it you
know cuz like I think the ghost stuff is
that's what that reminded me of a lot
this sort of like hey like creepy like
sleep like a new wave EJ horror I
thought that was really well done
yeah I've been the best one I think he's
put together well in terms of like a
serious short phone which is comedy
shorts and in serious shorts and jealous
serious short films I thought his acting
if I ever I want to talk about this in a
way where I can differentiate myself
from the fact that I am his brother
I thought his acting was really good I
think Anthony Jabby Kawai Alba's acting
is very like you know it's it's such a
visual piece and so much of the story
has to just unfold through watching him
yeah and I feel like his subtlety has
greatly improved he's put up some short
films from things he's shot like quite a
while ago and there are times where it
seems like he's kind of over remoting or
trying to show a little more and I
really felt like this time believing
Hugh in this moment I'm not being fully
going that's my brother
I'm actually really buying whatever he's
doing and the subtleties I thought were
really good in his performance one and I
see horror shorts a lot and I like that
this was this wasn't the same structure
the usual thing I'm used to seeing I
guess where it's like ooh a cool build
up in a punch line and yeah this felt
like a short film like yeah it felt like
a complete sort of and I like the
leaders of the old of I kind of the
silent film
school music playing over it to add a
different vibe and layer to it that
wasn't all about trying to build some
one no tension dread tone that a lot of
these horror shorts do I thought there
was a little bit more life to it yeah it
takes you a different places it's got
some dynamics and it's also got like a
great sense of rhythm yeah exactly
like I thought it was simple but
executed in a way that made it really
enjoyable and the photography is
beautiful the photography is actually in
it's between had they had the editing a
sharp and the sound of design is really
effective and the visual effects are
really good too when char pops out of
the water yeah you know she does that to
me all the time yeah never about to go
to the bathrooms it's just catching up
on those excellent I was very impressed
with it I'm so glad that neither one of
us has yet to star and one of the short
it's kind of made like cameo yeah we got
from one of ours too there's just a much
higher quality
well that's the thing is those are
funnier like from a movie but if it was
a Sam Raimi gonna be - this is like you
know oh you took some time and and put a
lot of thought into this it was written
and shot in two days
really oh boy we have work to do well we
got a graduate to his level good job
Anthony Jabby Cola the Star Wars ones
like my favorite in terms of just what
he's put together in terms of a short
film and the acting and the mood and how
chill story being complete I thought
that was really well done now I want to
see a full feature-length sequel with
this Lily girl looking for her boyfriend
that would be great it's just a story of
a bunch of people living in the pool
keeps dying before you know there's
they're running at her room
then you could tie it into the
Winchester franchise and have it be
selling they start convincing and some
killing whoever moves it now that just
convinced them to keep expanding the
pool in odd ways
well guys subscribe to jab eco is
Channel well done you can check out this
video link is in the description box to
watch the video in full-screen I don't
think it's worth it because the
cinematography is excellent here and
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell keep a lookout for our
short film that we are going to put
together right now we will have
completed not go to bed from Monday to
Tuesday and sleep all day through
Halloween